فاجنر تشعل توترا جديدا بين واشنطن وبيونغ
كوريا الشماليه غاضبه ازاء تقارير اعلاميه
تتهمها بتسليح مجموعه المرتزقه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
بان جمهوريه كوريا الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
قدمت ذخائر لروسيا هو ابشع هراء ولا يستحق
اي تعليق او التفسير
الشماليه ايضا بالولايات المتحده معتبره
انها تزود اوكرانيا باسلحه
لكنه ياتي بعد يوم من تصريح للبيت الابيض
الخارجيه الكوريه الشماليه انتقدت محاولات
الولايات المتحده اصدار بيان لمجلس الامن
التابع للامم المتحده بشان اطلاقها صاروخا
باليستيا عابرا للقارات مؤخرا صاروخ
بالستي يضاف الى عدد غير مسبوق من
الصواريخ اختبرتها كوريا الشماليه هذا
العام في تحدي للع قوبات الدوليه